do it anyway is a mindset trick that you
can use when you start to feel excuses
rolling up it works a lot like the five
second rule you have said to yourself
okay I'm gonna talk to my boss today
about that thing that I've been avoiding
talking to them about and then the
moment comes where you've got to have
that conversation or the moment comes
where it's time to pack up your bag and
leave your desk and go to the gym and
what always happens you don't feel like
it I bet there are plenty of you
watching that have made a commitment
that I'm not going to have a drink
tonight and then guess what happens when
you get home you don't feel like not
drinking you feel like having a drink
here's what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that I just do it anyway has
pushed me to realize and to recognize
that there are a lot of moments where
there are things in my life that I
really want to do I need to do but when
the moment comes I don't feel like it
and so I pull out this idea of you know
what I'm just gonna do it anyway it's
raining outside I said I would go for a
short run I don't don't feel like it I'm
gonna do it anyway it's six o'clock in
the morning I'm tired it's cold I laid
out my yoga clothes but now I don't feel
like it what do I do I do it anyway when
you start to say to yourself I'm gonna
do it anyway what happens is something
really cool you acknowledge that there
are feelings that you have that are
trying to swoop in and hijack you and
you basically say guess what I'm gonna
do it anyway need motivation you better
watch a top ten with believe Nation hey
it's Evan carmackle and I make these
videos because in my first business I
was making 300 bucks a month I quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
from one of the best Mel Robbins and my
take on our top 10 rules of success
enjoy
well number two keep dreaming whatever
it is that you're dealing with in your
life right now
it can put blinders on you because you
have to deal with your aging parent you
have to deal with the illness that's in
front of you
but it is so critical
that you still dream
why because dreams transport you from
the day to day dreams give you a beacon
to look up
because dreams will remind you that the
situation that you're facing right now
is temporary
dreams will remind you that even if the
situation isn't temporary let's say that
you've got some horrendous degenerative
disease
and so it's going to get worse not
better
dreams still give you a purpose
to live a bigger life despite what
you're dealing with
now you may not have the bandwidth to
pursue your dreams because of how sick
your parents are that's okay
It won't always be like this
but it is critical
that as a form of self-love as a form of
self-care that you still build the skill
of holding space for your dreams and
writing those dreams down every day and
thinking about those dreams and reading
about those dreams because they will
help you move through the chapter of the
life that you're in more powerfully more
grounded and more fulfilled rule number
three manage your fears we tend to think
about fear as something that's up here
you know that the fears are all in our
heads well the truth is your body feels
fear and remembers fear and senses fear
way before your mind does and the reason
why I want to talk to you about this is
because as many of you know we have a
brand new audiobook that just launched
with audible Originals so audible
Originals is an imprint inside of
audible we are our major partner of
Edibles and we just released a brand new
audiobook it's their number one new
release on Audible called take control
of your life how to silence fear and win
the mental game and there were some
unbelievable things that I learned and
that my team learned and that we're now
sharing with you in doing that project
so take control of your life isn't your
typical audiobook it's not me just
reading a book that I wrote what take
control of your life is is take control
of your life is a live coaching and
takeaway program that's 10 hours long
and so there are six people that you
meet when you listen to take control of
your life and they have fears just like
you have fears fears that are holding
them back just like you have fears that
hold you back fears that impact your
life in a negative way and we go session
by session for six sessions you listen
to the coaching session you hear about
somebody else's fear you hear me
coaching this person live and and then I
spend like 45 minutes unpacking the
entire coaching session for you and on
top of it you guys there's a 55-page
workbook that our team designed that
goes along as a companion to this
audiobook and you don't even need to buy
the audiobook to get the workbook or to
get the takeaways because I'm giving you
the takeaways for free here on our live
stream so if you want the audiobook just
go to melrobbins.com take control and
you can download the audiobook and what
I'm going to talk to you about today is
I'm going to talk to you about the
session that we did with Heather in take
control of your life and it's a really
incredible
um session because Heather
um is held back at work because what
happens is when she has to have a really
difficult conversation when there's
something that she wants to talk to her
boss about when there's a conflict with
one of her colleagues you ever have a
conflict with your colleagues at work
ever feel like you work in a toxic work
environment well this is something that
you need to understand
sometimes the toxicity in your work
environment is about the other people
and sometimes the toxicity in your work
environment or in your life environment
or your friend environment is about
stored memories in your body from your
childhood I know it's crazy stuff
because the saying Feel the fear and do
it anyway it's true because your body
feels situations that set you uh
that puts you in a state of being afraid
before your mind catches up and starts
thinking about what you're afraid of and
so one of the key takeaways from take
control and one of the things that I
want to teach you today is that if you
start to tune into your body and you
start to notice the signals that your
body is sending to you in your
day-to-day life signals like butterflies
in your stomach signals like feeling A
Rush of energy up to your neck signals
like your armpit sweating signals like
your hands getting sweaty signals that
your body is stepping and noticing a
situation that reminds it of your past
learning how to read those signals that
oh my God here goes my body my body is
starting to recognize that this is a
situation that puts me on edge
recognizing those signals first and
slowing the body response down before
your brain starts to go oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my God that is a
critical skill in taking control of your
life I want to tell you a little bit
about the science so there's this famous
Neuroscience is called Antonio demacio
and he did a really interesting study
where he discovered that our body senses
fear before our mind even realizes it
and when fear or danger
speaking to your boss calling a prospect
going to the gym when you're not proud
of the way that you look
um and you know it's not fear like
Terror it's more that low-grade
agitation in your body I felt it
yesterday because I went to a boot camp
class yesterday and I'm not in good
shape and I don't do boot crab Camp
classes and Kendall and I are staying at
this hotel where holy cow everybody
seems like there's some sort of
professional weight lifter or Instagram
model and so it was really intimidating
and I could feel
that agitation in my body that's the
kind of fear I'm talking about I'm not
talking about the paralysis fear your
life is threatened and you really are in
a life or death situation I'm talking
about the low-grade agitation
that is
um there when you're about to do
something that makes you feel a little
uncomfortable so when fear or dangerous
sensed in the body your body begins a
stress response before your mind even
catches up and if you want to take
control of your life you got to take
control of that physical state and it
starts with catching these moments
everyone
when you
um start to feel it okay and so for some
of you it may be a pit in the stomach
for some of you it may be tightening in
the chest for Heather who was one of the
people I coached and take control it was
this massive wave of heat that went into
her chest tightness or rash and then she
could start to feel that she was crying
you need to understand how do you react
to situations that make you nervous rule
number four build mental Fitness and you
got to view this moment like a test and
what is the test testing it's testing
Who You Are
that's part of the race right now how
you show up for it right it's not a
matter of how you finish it it's how you
show up for it and what you do while
you're running it the kind of racer that
you are and look I get it this is a very
difficult race that we're all running
because we don't know where the finish
line is and it is very very hard to stay
motivated which is the advice that
you're seeking Peter when you don't even
know when this damn thing is ending this
is the part of the race I've run four
marathons don't everybody gasp I mean it
was nothing to uh
to brag about I mean I finished them
which is which is something to brag
about but it's not like I won the damn
thing but this is the point in time when
you're running a race when you said
you're losing ground what that means is
you're starting to slow down you feel
your legs getting heavier you feel your
breath getting a little bit more shallow
you start to wonder oh why did I sign up
for this thing in the first place you
start to wonder if you are going to make
it and so here's what I'm going to tell
you Peter when you are coaching your
clients and your clients start to lose
ground when you are coaching your
clients and your clients don't feel
motivated and they feel tired and they
feel like giving up and they don't want
to do another set of burpees what do you
tell them you tell them to dig deeper
you tell them to find the strength
within them to keep going you see what
you need right now is you need to start
building the motivation of your mind
because motivation doesn't exist in your
body it comes from up here and what I
hear is that you now have an opportunity
this is what the test is Peter to train
harder because you are capable of so
much more
this is handing you a moment
where you get to become an even stronger
and more capable version of yourself now
does that mean that you're going to be
motivated all day long
uh every single day that you wake up no
but it means you've got to have the
mental Fitness right now to continue to
get up
to show up and to dig deeper when it
comes to your mindset when it comes to
your attitude when it comes to your
just knowing
that you are going to get through this
and so this moment everybody it's
telling you who you are
it's telling you whether or not you're
the kind of person that shows up to a
challenge and you're pissed off or
you're sad or you feel depressed or you
feel despair or you feel all of these
things that start to take you down the
drain of negativity and what I'm here to
tell you is that you are built for this
moment you may not feel like it you may
feel sad those are all normal feelings
you may feel negative it's very easy to
do you may start to feel a little bit of
Despair that's going to come and go but
this is where the test of this race that
we're currently running Lies when those
feelings rise up and you start losing
ground and you start feeling like you're
not going to make it to the finish line
and you start feeling unmotivated can
you dig deeper and remind yourself that
you were built for this moment because
one of the things that I know is that
when the is hitting the fan I guarantee
you there are people in your life that
are looking to you there are people in
your life whether it's clients or
colleagues or family members that are
looking to you right now you know what
that tells me that you're the kind of
person that people rely on and now is
the moment in time in the race that
we're all running where you got to teach
yourself to rely on yourself how do you
do that how do you build the muscle of
the Mind
it's very simple
very simple I didn't say easy I said
simple the steps are very simple
to win
this race
and to build strength in this muscle
right up here
you got to focus on the you can control
and that is what you do with your body
and what you do with your mind
and the one thing that has made a huge
difference in me because you can see
that I am showing up as a very different
Mel Robbins than I've been the last
couple weeks the last couple weeks I
have been losing the race I've been
going up and down I've been doing my
best to stay positive
but I am now back in the race I have now
found my ground and found my footing and
it comes in focusing on what you can
control and you know what you can
control there's only one thing
it's what are you doing to make this day
the best day that you can do what are
you doing to master this day to day
tomorrow forget about next week forget
about what's happening this summer this
is a race that will be won by those of
you
who are the ability to focus on today
and making today amazing also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five go big I want to
teach you how to train yourself to dream
big it's actually a skill and dreaming
big is something that we used to do as
kids right it was so easy as kids to sit
in class because you were bored with you
know whatever it was that your teacher
was doing and you started the Daydream
and as adults we tend to lose that
ability so the dream book is going to be
your companion to this program and
here's my philosophy about training
yourself to dream big again as an adult
in the dream book one of the things that
you're going to be doing as a daily
practice is you're going to do something
that I do in my book and that is every
time I crack this open because I keep my
notes in here is I write down the five
things that I dream about so I've
written down okay I'm super
super embarrassed that I've written this
down so I'm gonna tell you what my five
are and you can see you probably can't
see how red I'm turning because I have
so much makeup on because I was on in
television today and in television they
put a lot of makeup on you and digital I
normally look like but this is why we
all need to learn to dream big and to
dream authentically because when you
talk about it you immediately shrink
because we're trained not to have these
aspirations so the first thing that I
wrote down is I want to be the number
one talk show in the United States you
know what's so fascinating is I used to
dream of just actually being where I am
and now that I've achieved that I have a
dream that's even bigger and what does
it mean and why is this dream important
to me and this is part of what you're
going to learn in the workbook but I'll
tell you why the stream is important to
me because if we are number one it means
that the work that we're doing that I
care so deeply about which is helping
people heal their minds and heal their
relationships and to live a more
positive happy mentally well life that
we're reaching more people that's what
that means and that's why I want it I
wrote down number one New York Times
bestseller I have for years said I don't
give a about it but I actually do I
guess and I think it's because it would
be really nice
to have the powers that be actually
acknowledge the impact that we're making
do I need it to keep going forward no of
course not and I will keep going forward
I want to make the time 100 list for
mental health and for the work that
we're doing and the reason why is
because as much as I like being an
entrepreneur that does things in a very
Innovative way that kind of public
recognition brings with it resources and
partners that would allow you to make an
even bigger impact and so when I think
about that kind of recognition it
challenges me to dream so much bigger
that I'm Dreaming right now about the
impact that I want to make in mental
health the fourth one this is not my
dream right now but I wrote this down
three days ago and that is to be the
happiest I've ever been living in
Vermont
the reason why I wrote that down at the
time is because my son is going to go to
high school in Vermont and we are
grappling with a move and I had a mental
breakdown when we started looking at
houses there thinking I couldn't live
here one of the interesting things about
dreaming is your dreams will change I
love the daily practice of writing in
your dream book the five things you're
dreaming about because you'll notice
that there are things that show up
consistently for you and that's a sign
that it's important to pay attention to
it it's important to walk toward it and
by writing I dream that I'd be the
happiest I'd ever be in Vermont I was
doing the work of trying to shift my
attitude about how I was feeling about a
move when I'm not that excited about it
right now the fifth one is I want to
build a summer house I grew up on Lake
Michigan I've spent the last 30 years
not on the water I dream to be
successful enough that someday in the
next decade I will have the money to buy
a fantastic piece of property on the
ocean and I will build an awesome house
that is a gathering place for our family
and hopefully that will not include
grandchildren in the next decade rule
number six quiet your anxiety I'm going
to be talking to you about the
connection
between worrying
and anxiety
and how it is critical if you want to
quiet your anxiety
if you want to stop worrying if you want
to get control over what you're thinking
about it's going to begin with a habit
that you have that somebody else trained
you that you've gotten really good at
this habit and you know what the Habit
is it's the habit of worrying we all do
it we're all guilty of it we're all
um guilty of sorry let me just move that
a little bit we're all guilty of
worrying about things that are beyond
our control worrying about things that
doesn't matter worrying about things
that we shouldn't care about sorry I've
got the streaming lights uh anymore hold
on let me just ask Mandy a question
um worrying about all kinds of things
that you shouldn't worry about and it
becomes a habit it becomes a default way
of thinking and so in order to kick off
anxiety week I want to explain
um the connection between
um worrying
and why that impacts anxiety and now
since we're talking about anxiety I have
to be very clear about something okay I
am not a therapist
I am a individual who struggled
personally with anxiety for more than
two decades I took Zoloft which was a
lifesaver and I strongly believe in
trying medication when a professional
believes that you are so in a hole
mentally that medication will give you
the ability to start to claw your way
out of that hole
um I have learned so much about anxiety
because of my own struggles and five
years ago I trained myself to be a
deliberate thinker just like I'm
training you to be a deliberate thinker
in this program and through everything
that I am about to teach you and all of
the
um all of the the strategies that you're
about to learn
I learned all of these by researching
anxiety and I Road tested them on myself
while I was still in therapy and I then
started going off of my medication and
as my mindset reset and as my thinking
patterns became more positive and
stronger and healthier I was able to
completely cure myself of anxiety and I
say that with the utmost of relief and
confidence and I have also used gone on
to use these exact same techniques that
I'm going to teach you to help my
children deal with their anxieties I've
written extensively about anxiety in the
five second rule book which is right
behind me we've sold almost a million
copies of that book it is the number one
self-published audiobook in the history
of audible I'm so proud of it and I
speak at length about anxiety and using
the five second rule to cure yourself
of anxiety okay but I need to make it
very clear that these training sessions
are in no way no way a substitute for
getting professional help if you have
the kind of clinical
anxiety or you suffer from an anxiety
disorder it is Paramount that you seek
professional help from a therapist
one-on-one that you try remarkable
um therapies uh I'm gonna say it wrong
but it's uh edrm or erdm which is the
rapid eye movement therapy incredibly
helpful and so don't be a hero don't go
off your meds cold don't quit therapy
because you think that this live
training program is the answer this live
training program is a step and this live
training program for the next week in
particular while we talk about anxiety
you're going to be introduced to tools
that are grounded in research and tools
that have worked for millions of people
and tools that you can take back to your
therapist or take back to whatever
counseling you get to help you become a
deliberate thinker which will help you
quiet your anxiety get control of it and
then ultimately cure it with the help of
a professional if you have an anxiety
Disorder so
uh said
please please please listen to
everything that I'm about to tell you
and try it okay
please try it because this stuff works
if you practice it and again quieting
anxiety it's not an event it's not a one
and done this is a process that you're
going to repeat over and over and over
again because the connection between
anxiety
and your mindset
begins with your habit of worrying
we have a question from Twitter is
worrying the same as overthinking if
you're overthinking about positive stuff
and keeping yourself in an excited state
no it's not if you're overthinking and
the overthinking is you spinning
scenarios in your mind that are negative
yes
overthinking is another word when it's
negative for worrying on overdrive it
means that you worry in loops and you
keep repeating the worry over and over
and over as if you were washing the same
load of laundry over and over and over
again and so we're starting with the
habit of worrying worrying about things
that don't matter
worrying about things that you can't
control worrying about things that
haven't happened yet worrying about
things that are far off in the future
when you start to train yourself to
think about things
that are not in your control
or think about things that are
statistically likely never to happen
that is when you can get into trouble
and that's why we're going to start with
worrying you see worrying
is when you allow your mind to default
on autopilot and think about things that
don't serve you
think about things that are outside of
your control rule number seven innovate
yourself here's another massive Insight
so I always think about businesses
levels right and I also realize that as
the media landscape or the
um the particular vertical or industry
that you're building a business in is
changing that is a constant and it's
something that you can't control right
you just cannot control the things that
are happening in the world around us but
you can always control what you're
thinking and what you're doing in
response to it so all of my work Centers
inside this gap between what's happening
in your life and in your work and what
your reaction is to it and how you can't
control
the things that are going on around you
but you can always control what your
reaction is and that Gap there that's
about five seconds long and you start to
understand that you can change how you
think you can change your habits you can
change how you lead you can pivot and
change even the philosophy of your
company and you can do it through the
decisions that you're making and
managing your reactions you will become
Unstoppable so three years three and a
half years ago I got into the speaking
business
um because of the popularity of that
tedx talk that I gave and
um that first year I did
um I don't know I think was like 27
speeches the next year I did 87 last
year I did 121 I was the most book
female speaker in the world this year
I've capped it at 80 and here's why I
realized just like you may be realizing
in your business whatever your business
is that there are aspects of your
business that you love and that energize
you and there are aspects of your
business that are depleting as hell and
that are old and that are tired and that
if you continue in that lane you're
going to end up 10 years from now in a
place that you don't want to be it's so
important for you to pay attention to
what's energizing you about the
landscape around you and about your own
business because that's the secret to
seeing around corners and so the corner
that I was seeing around is that as an
entrepreneur even though it's wildly
lucrative to do what I do just on the
speaking platform I mean anybody can do
the math on 121 speeches right and the
amount of money that I get paid to show
up and deliver a one-hour talk and
realize there's a lot of money here's
the problem it's a terrible business
because you can't scale it other than
raising your price or raising the number
of of times you do it and guess what
else you have to show up
and I can't sell it
so I found myself in a situation where I
had built a multi-million dollar
business highly profitable and it was
depleting the hell out of me and I can't
really scale it and I can't sell it
terrible position to be in in an
entrepreneur so I made a decision that I
you know what was it Beau that actually
energizes me about my business and I
answered it with the first question it's
hearing from people
I would rather answer comments on
Instagram all day long than stand in a
stadium with 5 000 people in it I get
more from the one-to-one connection
that's what fuels me and so I have this
light bulb moment paying attention being
clear that wait a minute I don't want to
build
the biggest speaking platform and I
don't want to build a coaching business
I want to build a Content company I want
to go back to my roots and build a media
company and so with that Insight I now
have to change right because the kind of
business woman that runs a
multi-multi-million dollar
speaking business where it's just you
and your speaking management firm and
your travel folks and your Logistics
people and maybe your social media
manager that's who's on the team the
kind of leader that runs that kind of
team is very different than the kind of
leader that is going to grow a hundred
million dollar Media company that's
going to Syndicate content every single
day that is going to own what she's
doing that's going to build Instagram
and Facebook and YouTube and Linkedin as
my personal ABC CNBC Fox and this is
what I want you to understand about the
story and that is this in order to get
to the next level in your business you
got to decide right now what habits do
you have as a leader that you have to
change now because you will not see
around the corner you will not engineer
that next Quantum Leap unless you
personally change and so one of the
reasons why I've gone from being the
most successful female you know book
speaker on the speaking circuit to
launching the number one book on all of
the self-publishing platform for Amazon
and one of the most read books in the
world and selling like Buster still is
because I am constantly innovating
myself
I know that I am the single biggest
problem in my company
and if I don't constantly pivot and
evolve how I lead and what I'm focused
on I'm gonna be the blockade and so you
know stop looking at what everybody else
is doing stop micromanaging the team and
ask yourself two years from now when you
think about where you want your company
to be what habit do you have to change
right now rule number eight push things
forward the thing about procrastination
is it's triggered by stress so you're
cleaning
is being triggered by stress and there's
only one way to deal with this pattern
you have to interrupt it so when you
catch yourself cleaning next time that's
a moment of power because you're you're
now present you're like oh my God here I
am cleaning again use the five second
rule five four three two one two switch
gears in your brain and get control in
the moment and then I want you to just
do one thing on your side hustle that's
it drop the cleaning stuff walk over
send one email on your side hustle write
one paragraph of content do one thing
and here's why here's why I want you to
focus on doing one thing or working for
five minutes that's it set a timer for
five minutes I'm gonna work on content
for five minutes we know based on the
research that your eighty percent eighty
percent of the time you're gonna keep
going past the five minutes because the
issue isn't that you don't know how to
create content the issue is that when
you start to feel stressed out you go to
cleaning it's a pattern that you've
trained yourself to do the only way to
interrupt that pattern is to bring break
it and insert a new one okay and
like something about
uh procrastination and perfectionism
okay
because how many of you struggle with
being a perfectionist yeah yeah I'm sure
um
the thing about those of you who are
perfectionists
is that um it is it's not about being
perfect
perfectionism is really your attempt to
be in control
and we're seeing a massive rise in the
number of people that struggle with
perfectionism and I think it has to do
with the fact that our culture is now so
focused on performing from an early
childhood from how you doing school to
being on the right club team and then
it's the travel team and then it's the
this team and then it's recruiting for
college and the way that we parent our
kids and helicoptering and swooping down
and and the pressure of college and the
pressure to achieve and the the concern
that you're going to make a mistake I
mean this has become a
self-imposed epidemic and so if you are
somebody who struggles with
perfectionism you can't turn in
something at work until it's perfect you
can't finish the paper until it's
perfect you can't even start with
redecorating your room until you know
the perfect color that this is really
about control you are uncomfortable
just being in the flow you're
uncomfortable with the unknown and the
most important thing here is to realize
that this is a pattern
and you absolutely have to break free of
the need to do everything right
and to get into the mode of just being
willing to try
get into the mode of understanding hey
if I turn in something at work that's
not like perfect I'll get feedback and
then I'll make it right like in the work
and in the willingness to just keep
pushing things down the line keep
showing up keep raising your hand even
though you're not sure you're going to
say it right keep contributing keep
asking for feedback you a thousand
percent
will slowly lose the grip of being a
perfectionist because the only way to
break that pattern is to realize oh my
God I'm trying to keep control and
that's why I'm holding on to this paper
that's why I'm torturing myself that's
why I'm doing everything
the magic is in the willingness to push
things forward to try to get in the flow
to basically say I'm either gonna I'm
just gonna do my best that's it I'm not
gonna do it right
I'm going to just try I'm going to do my
best and when I get feedback on how I
can do it better that's how I'm going to
learn
uh you know I am a lifelong learner I
don't ever think I'm going to do
anything perfect
um I
this is not something I struggle with
anymore because I have broken this
pattern in my mind and realized that all
of the all of the opportunity and Magic
comes from you being willing to put
yourself out there when you're not
perfect being willing to do things and
start things when you haven't figured it
out and understanding that when you get
into the flow and into the conversation
and into the live stream that you can
get into problem solving mode and you
can figure it out rule number nine set a
good morning routine your mindset and
having a powerful mindset and being
deliberate about what you're going to
think about and what you're not going to
think about it begins the moment you
wake up and believe it or not how you
wake up not when but how you wake up and
the first few things that you do in the
morning will dictate your mood for the
rest of the day which based on science
is going to impact your productivity and
it's going to impact how you feel about
your life and it will also impact
your mindset for the rest of the day and
that's why now that we've done in days
one two three four and five we've done
foundational training you've learned a
tremendous amount about how your brain
works about your default Network about
how to be a deliberate thinker you've
spotted your limiting beliefs you've
learned how to think this not that
you've started the skill and the
practice of the skill remember it's a
process not an event to be a positive
thinker you've started practicing
catching your limiting beliefs and
swapping from that default way of
viewing the world and thinking about
yourself and choosing deliberate
thoughts now let's talk about physical
habits that you can adopt that are very
simple that will be life-changing
because they will impact your ability to
be in control of what you're thinking
and to be deliberate and that begins
with how you wake up so let me talk
about the morning
you can think about your morning routine
and whether or not you even have one in
the exact same way that we think about
the brain you're either defaulting to
something that you've always done that
may not no longer serve you or you're
getting deliberate and choosing to do
something that's more positive and
Powerful because you deserve it and that
starts with your morning routine so if
you're the kind of person where the
alarm goes off and you hit the snooze
and then the alarm goes off again and
you hit the snooze and you know
eventually you roll out of bed and you
step into your day and you maybe drink a
big dark cup of coffee and you skip
breakfast and you skip exercise and
you're tired if that's how you start
your day
your mindset is going to be impacted by
that if your alarm goes off and you
immediately reach for your phone and you
start scrolling through Instagram while
you're in bed and looking at Facebook
and you are putting all kinds of stuff
in your brain that triggers fomo that
triggers insecurity that triggers
anxiety that is going to impact your
mindset for the rest of the day and so
starting tonight I want you to take
control and be more deliberate about
your habits in the morning and what
we're going to do this week is we are
going to build based on science the most
powerful morning routine that you could
possibly have sorry I'm just moving this
around so the Instagram channel is
brighter the most powerful morning
routine that you could possibly have
based on science it's super simple it
will help you become a more deliberate
and positive thinker and I'm going to
walk you through step by step and you're
going to be doing this with more than
230 000 people around around the world
so what is the assignment tonight the
assignment tonight is very simple
and you're gonna hate it
you're totally able to do this
and most of you are not going to you're
going to let your limiting beliefs and
your default mode of thinking stop you
from making this simple change and the
thing that I want you to do tonight this
is your assignment
this Smartphone right here
I don't want it anywhere near your
bedroom your assignment is when you go
to bed tonight you are to plug your
smartphone in
outside of your bedroom if you live in a
studio apartment put it on the other
side of the room
I don't want this phone anywhere near
where you sleep
and there's a simple reason why
you're addicted to it and if it's next
to you while you're sleeping
as soon as you wake up
without even thinking the default mode
of your brain
will mindlessly reach for this and you
will lie in bed and you will look at
your phone
and when you do that you are putting in
garbage into your brain before you even
get out of bed if you wake up anxious if
you wake up overwhelmed if you wake up
feeling like you're losing some
imaginary race if you wake up and you
feel dread if you wake up and feel
negative or exhausted I'm telling you
this is the reason why
and if you want to have a positive
mindset this year and you deserve to
then you also have to get very
deliberate about your habits and about
your morning routine in particular
because how you wake up matters how you
wake up determines your mood how you
wake up determines on your phone hold on
IG is pausing a lot hold on a second
let's see here
um yikes all right hold on a second IG
uh
I'm getting a lot of uh let's get on
Wi-Fi
Rendezvous let's see if that works
looks like I'm on
let's go back to Instagram okay let's
see if that works is that better Mandy
um
thank you for your patience by the way
normally our streams are not as spotty
but when we started this program I knew
that I was going to be traveling 24 out
of the 35 days that we're broadcasting
live and Tech can be a challenge and so
for those of you that have been hanging
in there on Instagram if it's body jump
over to Facebook live jump over to
YouTube jump over to Twitter we're
streaming on all four platforms at once
and we will also email you a link to
this video which is one of the reasons
why if you haven't yet sign up for
melrobbins.com mindset reset because we
curate all this information for you and
we tee it up for you every day
um so thank you for your patience as I
am broadcasting from uh my parents place
my mother's 70th birthday is tomorrow
and
um for those of you that are just tuning
in because the stream has been dicey
we're talking about the powerful
connection between your mindset and your
morning routine in fact I would say it's
not even powerful it's critical
you cannot have a positive in control
mindset if you don't have control of
your mornings angle number 10 the last
time before some very special bonus
Clips is stop doubting yourself the
barrier is everybody gives a
where people are thinking yeah
and so they're on camera or they're on a
microphone trying to be smart or
concerned about whether or not they look
good in the shot uh concerned about uh
how they sound whether or not they
started if their neck is turning red
like whatever it may be and they're so
up here that they're not actually being
true to just saying what's right here
absolutely whether you're speaking from
the heart speaking from the gut like
that is the skill to develop is the
ability to be more like an 11 year old
that gets on camera and can just be
themselves instead of being a 49 year
old person censoring themselves
and that's what I'm talking about when I
talk about the truth when I talk about
authenticity that people really want to
feel that connection and the only way
that they're going to feel that
connection is if you do the work to
remove the own veneer and the own
barriers that you put in between you and
other people and the number one thing is
everybody gives too much of a about what
everybody else thinks and you know who
they think the more they're worried the
most about they're friends
if I put this thing up not for my
friends but for the people that I'm
trying to build a rapport with online my
friends are going to judge me your
friends seriously if you're out to make
a difference if you're out to share
something that is important to you if
your friends don't like it or don't
support you they're really not your
friends absolutely
you know yeah and it's a really hard
lesson it's a very hard lesson because
everybody's always judging everybody
else that's why you can't worry about it
yeah
recommendations for
how started like for moving from that
like to basically move from their
mindset of I care too much to I don't
care as much like are there steps that
you recommend people the only step that
really works is action because if you're
stopping to think
about what people are thinking or
whether or not you're worried about what
people are thinking you've already
fallen into the Trap the second that you
push yourself to get started through the
action itself you are proving to
yourself that even though you care what
everybody thinks you're gonna do it
anyway okay and so that's why I talk
about the five second rule the five
second rule is how you interrupt the
excuses the patterns the concerns and
the fears that you have whether it's
perfectionism whether it's disappointing
your parents whether it's being judged
by your friends whether it's looking
stupid when you post something whether
it's screwing up and saying something
that a bunch of trolls come after you
for right all those things that
everybody's concerned about that can
stop you forever if you go five four
three two one you break the part of the
brain where all of those trappings are
and you awaken your prefrontal cortex
which is the part of the brain that
you're using when you're creating
content when you're speaking with
courage when you're learning something
new and so that's why this simple brain
trick that I invented is exploding
around the world because every last one
of us is exactly the same exactly the
same you and I we want the same thing we
want to actually live a life where we
get to express ourselves at the highest
level
we're all want the day the same thing
and we're all stopping ourselves the
same way by thinking too much by buying
into the lies that self-doubt tells you
and so I'm here to tell you you can cut
that off at the knees five four three
two one you can make a five second
decision the second you feel that doubt
the second you feel that concern the
second you feel that fruit that fear and
you can literally feel it and actually
move anyway
I used to be the kind of person that had
zero boundaries I mean not a nothing
zilch nothing in fact there were periods
of my life where it was worse than zero
because I was so attached in romantic
relationships that I literally would
become like a human amoeba in my
romantic relationships I mean I was like
literally if it's possible to have
negative boundaries meaning you like
somehow go in a totally different
direction that was me and so if somebody
as insecure and as uh emotionally
attached in relationships and as people
pleasing as me can figure out how to
identify
communicate and uphold boundaries in my
life you can learn how to do this too
okay and so that's what we're gonna
unpack in this video
so I think a big question because a lot
of people talk about boundaries they
know they need boundaries but they don't
have good boundaries why is that
well the reason why we don't have good
boundaries is because none of us were
trained how to set them I mean I want
you to think about your childhood for a
minute your childhood with your
caregivers your parents your
grandparents whoever it is naturally an
imbalance right like when you come into
this world you are born into a
particular family you're born into a
particular culture religion economic
situation a place in the world a race
like a religion and based on where you
were born and to whom you were born into
in terms of the family structure there
were all kinds of rules that you had to
follow and if you did not follow those
rules
there were consequences and so can you
imagine if you as like an eight-year-old
started to try to express boundaries
literally like mom cooks a uh you know a
pot pot roast dinner and you cross your
arms you're like you know Mom
uh this is a boundary cross for me I
have decided that I am no longer eating
meat uh your mom would probably go guess
what youngster you not eating dinner is
a boundary Crossing for me you're not
getting up from this table until you
finish what's on your plate and so
saying boundaries when you're little
doesn't really work for the adults in
your life and that's why you never
learned how to do it and by the way your
parents were probably never taught how
to have boundaries either and so
I want to start at the very beginning
okay
where do you even begin where do you
even begin when it comes to learning how
to set healthy boundaries okay so first
things first where you're going to begin
is you're going to start to think about
boundaries in a completely new way okay
the number one mistake that we all make
I made it you're making it right now is
when you think about boundaries you are
thinking about other people first okay
you're thinking about boundaries uh and
believing that your boundaries are rules
in a relationship that define respect
and that somehow your boundaries are
going to control or change someone
else's Behavior that is the exact
opposite of how you should be thinking
about boundaries okay I didn't realize
this this is why I was lousy at setting
boundaries because I thought that my
boundaries control what other people do
no no no no no no so how do I want you
to think about boundaries okay
boundaries are rules that you create
about your own behavior and I'm gonna
take this a little bit further now
what I'm actually talking about is I'm
going to help you identify situations
people
um any kind of experience you might find
yourself in
where your boundary defines what you're
going to do in reaction to something
that's going on around you okay because
I think what I'm seeing a lot of online
are two things
it's this sort of quick Instagram advice
where it's like you've crossed a
boundary you're a toxic person you're no
longer in my life when the truth is the
behavior that we really need to be
policing is our own the opportunity for
growth and the way the boundaries can
support you is in looking at what you
need to change when it comes to certain
people certain situations or certain
choices and habits that you have okay
and we're gonna unpack this don't worry
but I really want to kind of land here
because if you start to turn the focus
back on yourself you're going to have a
much easier time with
applying the five rules around
boundaries that I'm about to teach you
okay so rule number one
always focus on yourself
what you will and what you won't allow
okay always focus on yourself what you
will and won't allow do not try to
control other people because you can't
okay think about boundaries as guard
rails that you set for yourself and I'm
going to give you a quick example we all
have that relative that loves to hear
them talk about politics right like it's
super annoying they're constantly going
on and on about politics okay and you
want this relative of yours to stop
talking about politics around you okay
what if I told you that expressing a
boundary with a relative telling them to
stop talking about politics around you
will probably only increase the
likelihood that they're going to
and so the better way to think about
boundaries is not
what do I need to say to Uncle Joe so
that Uncle Joe does not talk about
politics around me
that's not how you do this you don't go
Uncle Joe you're crossing a line with me
you're crossing a boundary I need you to
stop talking about politics
let's just role play that for a minute
how do you think that's going to work
that ain't gonna work very well is it no
because then Uncle Joe's going to flare
up and then you're gonna flare up and
now instead of having a boundary that
you held you've got a gigantic mess
that's been made instead you got to
think about that boundary with you okay
what are you going to do
and there are two examples of this you
could decide
that if that relative starts sounding
off about politics
that is a boundary for you and you will
remove yourself from the room
that's an example of how you can set a
boundary
another example is you could say
something to Uncle Joe and you could say
hey Uncle Joe
I love you
and I'd love to have you over for dinner
but if you plan on talking about
politics when we're together
We're not gonna have dinner
you have defined what you will tolerate
and not you didn't say do not talk about
politics you said I love you if we're
gonna have dinner together I'd love to
have you over for dinner
but not if we're talking politics
you've given Uncle Joe the option to
talk politics or not you've just made it
clear where you stand which is we're not
having dinner together if you opt to do
that do you see how that's about your
behavior
you've made it clear what you're gonna
do but Uncle Joe now has a choice to
either respect the boundary or not you
want to focus on what's in your control
okay
that's what you want to do if you're
going through a divorce you're waiting
for lawyers and this process of
anticipation this process of having to
be patient the first thing that you need
to do is ask yourself and this is by the
way stuff that I talk about in the high
five habit book this is about how to
cultivate a high five attitude when
things are out of your control how to
cultivate a high five attitude when you
are waiting and are feeling this
anticipation how to cultivate a high
five attitude when you might be
disappointed I mean you're not going to
have everything be a win in life and so
rule number one
you want to put a hundred and fifty
percent
effort in on something that you care
about okay so if you are sitting here
and you're waiting to hear back on
something or you're waiting to do
something you want to ask yourself if I
put a hundred and fifty percent in one
of the reasons why I just fired off
literally a three-page detailed email to
this landlord basically saying these
girls need a win they all have uh jobs
after working uh internships uh their
senior year they are respectful they're
not looking at your house like a frat
house like so many other people will
they need individual rooms in case they
have to work remote like I went boom
boom boom boom boom they're looking for
a home why did I do that because I think
it's really important when you are
trying to uh make something happen in
your life
really important when you're going for
something that you can personally say to
yourself I have done a hundred and fifty
percent I have gone all in okay and so I
feel like yeah we went all in we got our
application in we got the check
submitted we got the uh Love Letter
submitted and now what I do when I'm
waiting is I literally say I've put in a
hundred and fifty percent I can give
myself that high five I can look the
woman in the mirror and I can say I know
I did everything that I could what will
eat you alive everybody
is if you're waiting and you know that
you didn't put 150 percent in
it will eat you alive to be
waiting to hear back on a job or on
um you know some test results or on an
application to a program or a school and
to know that you didn't put in 150
percent that's what's going to cause the
disappointment who can relate to this
you feel like you're not worthy of the
things that you're accomplishing or that
somehow this is luck or somebody's like
giving you a break but you didn't earn
it God every one of you that blows
really
so what you're dealing with when you
have imposter syndrome is you're dealing
with a lack of self-worth
you literally
kind of see all the things working out
but you've got this like annoying voice
in your head that's saying you don't
deserve this this is locked how many of
you have that story this is locked this
is going to run out this isn't due to me
yeah we got to literally destroy that
voice that is from your past
and part of the reason why you have that
boy that voice by the way is because of
racism it's because of discrimination
it's because of childhood trauma it's
because of uh various experiences that
you've had where either your experiences
growing up or Society at large has made
you feel either overtly or in a really
like gross and sort of Sly way like you
don't belong and so it is critical for
you to start to punch that voice
literally out of your head and I'm going
to give you some steps to do it okay
the second thing that's really important
is that in addition to stopping down
that voice because it's not your voice
that is somebody else's voice that your
brain listened to
and then started repeating
and the thing about your brain is that
your brain is this really cool computer
that learns patterns
and what I want you to understand is
that patterns repeat
unless you break and replace them
and if you have a pattern of thinking
like what Heidi has
that says you're not worthy you don't
deserve this luck is going to run out at
some point that you know what's going to
hit the fan again
brace
don't count on anything
like you didn't earn this if you got
that pattern running in your head that
is a broken pattern
you're not broken
that pattern of thinking is broken
and so the Line in the Sand that I want
to draw starting today is you're not
allowed to listen to that garbage
anymore
we are going to go on a mission together
to notice whenever it comes up oh
interesting there it is there's that
pattern it's spinning just like a load
of laundry right up there and I'm going
to teach you once you recognize that
pattern you're going to use this thing
that I created called the five second
rule you're going to count backwards
five four three two one because that
shuts that down
and counting backwards let's all do it
together here we go five four three two
one now notice when you counted did you
feel a little pressure right here
yeah that was me hypnotizing you no I'm
just kidding
um
what you were feeling
is by counting backwards it's a little
brain hack
that interrupts all the garbage that's
here in the interior part of your brain
this is where imposter syndrome lives
everybody this is where anxiety is this
is where self-doubt is this is where
self-criticism is this is where it's all
stored when you notice oh there's that
voice again and you count backwards five
four three two one you shut it down
and then you awaken this part of your
brain this is the part of the brain that
you used when you were taking the SATs
this is the part of the brain that you
used when you applied for that job when
you speak up in that meeting when you
tell somebody no you cannot borrow my
dress tonight no when you have
boundaries right this is the part of the
brain that gives you immediate control
over what you think and do next
and so that's a really important thing
one of the things that has happened uh
certainly in the pandemic but it always
happens when there's any kind of
Reckoning in your life
is that when you have something suddenly
happen and your life is fundamentally
changed whether it's a death or somebody
says I don't love you anymore or you're
fired or you find yourself with a scary
Health diagnosis there is a line in the
sand there is a life before
that happened and then a life after that
moment happened and that line in the
sand that Reckoning that happens and it
happens for all of us whether it's
happening for you right now or it has
happened in the past I'm telling you
there is a gift inside of this even the
darkest moments because every single
Sudden Change in your life that makes
you feel like you've lost control and
you no longer know where you're going
it's like hitting the giant pause button
and if you lean into the moment
there is a chance for tremendous wisdom
and growth there are things that you can
do right now in order to take control of
where you're going of what you're
thinking about and you can start to take
this moment of change and you can use it
to be able to take and make an
intentional pivot in the direction that
is meant for you next and one of the
things I want to say about this moment
is look if you're losing loved ones you
are terrified this has made you lose
your job you feel like you're in that
moment where everything you know you're
falling off a cliff you're trying to
pack a parachute you're grieving and so
you got to give yourself space to grieve
the losses that you're feeling and when
you get a little bit of distance from
The Grieving and the ways of grief and
fear that you're feeling start to space
out they don't ever leave you but over
time those waves of holy cow and I don't
want this and I can't handle this and
why is this happening to me
time will start to lessen those waves
you will gather your feet underneath you
again and you will absolutely
be stronger and be a better version of
yourself based on this incredible
challenge that you're facing and I can
say that even though you may be facing
in a tough time because if you think
about your life you faced extraordinary
challenges and there hasn't been a
single one that hasn't made you a better
and stronger version of yourself and
this moment will be no different so I
want you to understand that when you get
out of the cycle of grief this is an
enormous Reckoning an enormous
opportunity for you to hit the pause
button and for you to start to ask
yourself the question what do I want my
life to look like
because I think too many of us are
sitting here going I can't wait for my
life to get back to normal I can't wait
for this to end I can't wait to things
to go back to normal and in any moment
of Reckoning what happens is there's
actually parts of your old life
that you don't want to go back to
and there is a tremendous amount that
you're learning in this moment that you
need to pause and take in and say okay
based on what I've just learned based on
my old life when I look ahead to my new
life what is it that I want my new life
to look like this next chapter I can
turn to a blank page I can take all this
wisdom all this resilience all this
strength and I can write something new
that's what I want you to know you don't
need to know where the world or where
everything is headed you just need to
know where you're gonna head next for
years
hesitation
kept me trapped in my head
hesitation made me doubt myself
hesitation kept me from taking the
actions and
taking the small risks
that change your life
and you have a habit of hesitating
hesitating is this little habit that we
all have and you know I obviously
invented the five second rule which is a
tool that you can use to push through
the hesitation that holds you back
and to break that habit of hesitating
and to replace it with an action of
moving forward
but there's an area in your life where
you are hesitating
you know what you want or you at least
know you don't want what you currently
have
and you think a lot about what you need
to do or what you could do or what you
wish would happen
and all that thinking that you're doing
that is the problem
you're not going to change your life
you're not going to get what you want if
all you do is think about it
and
I want to challenge you
I think that there is some change you
want to make something that you want to
do and you're sitting there questioning
it whether it's
going back to school or launching that
business or moving to a different place
or breaking up with somebody or changing
up your exercise program
there's something that you want to do
and I want you to put in the comments
what's that thing that you really want
to have a breakthrough in or you want to
change but all you do is think about it
and think about it and think about it
maybe it's your job maybe it's your
health maybe it's your relationship
well I know one thing that a lot of you
are hesitating on right now is jumping
into this new program that I have called
launch
I'm going to talk about it in a minute
but for those of you that are not
considering launch that's cool I want
you to get something out of our
conversation right now
habit of hesitating
conditioning
kills more happiness more possibility
more dreams than fear failure and every
excuse that you have
subtle
you see what happens to you is that
throughout your day you are going
through your day and as you bump into
people or you have experiences or you
see things on social media or you're
reading a book you have this impulse or
this inspiration this moment where
you're like oh gosh I'd really I'd love
to launch a business like that or oh I'd
love to launch a podcast or maybe I
should write a book someday or you know
whoa uh I should really get serious
about that thing that I want to do
and then
instead of taking a step forward
you stop and think about it
so I see Stephen wants to stop smoking I
see that
um you know a lot of you want to launch
your business or change your job learn
how to invest in real estate full-time
that there's a lot that you're thinking
about
but this moment of hesitation
what happens when you stop and think is
you literally get trapped in your head
and the more that you think about this
thing whether it's real estate investing
or launching a business or changing your
health or quitting smoking or
whatever it may be
maybe it's just mindset maybe you just
wish you weren't so negative all the
time maybe you wish you could be happier
that's something I'm working on in this
chapter of my life learning how to allow
myself
to be happier
learning how to be okay with everything
that's happening and everything that's
not I mean that would be a huge change
for somebody like me who is so type A
and so hard charging and so driven to
learn how to just be happy and okay no
matter what's happening
that would be enough
that's something I'm working on but
thinking about it that's not going to
help
so as you write down an area of your
life where you're hesitating I want to
tell you the simple truth
the only thing that is going to change
that relationship that job your
financial situation your attitude your
mental health your friendships your
relationship with your family the only
thing that's going to change that is
action
you got to learn how to launch through
the excuses the fear all of that crap
that's holding you back what is it that
you want to create
or change in your life okay I want you
to write something down it could be
something tiny that there's like a
specific thing that you want to change a
specific habit or it could be something
really big and it's important that we
start there because I want you
to have the thing that you want in mind
as I'm talking okay what is it that you
want to create in 2022 wealth stability
you want to stop
procrastinating right you want to create
Independence you want to feel like
you're aligned you want to uh get your
education you want to change your
exercise and eating habits you don't
want to be a passenger in somebody
else's life anymore you want to be The
Driver of your own life that's fantastic
and as I talk and as I teach I want you
to continue to think about this goal
that you have to think about this change
that you want to make okay and what
we're going to talk a lot about today
is we're going to talk about this
principle
that I believe
and the principle is this
profound personal and professional
change starts with you
that's right profound personal and
professional change starts with you
and change starts with you because the
most effective change starts from the
inside out okay and so as you think
about a behavior change or a thinking
pattern change that you want to make or
some sort of goal or dream I want you to
take everything that I'm about to teach
you
and have that example in mind okay so
that everything that I'm talking about
isn't just stuff I'm doing in my life
isn't just stuff that you read about uh
when you look at the research in terms
of habits and manifesting but you
actually walk away with takeaway that is
specific to what you want to achieve the
reason why habits are so important
everybody
is because based on uh research this is
from a study that was published a couple
years ago that 40 of your behavior are
what we call Habits
habits
that's just another word for patterns
okay and so I'm going to give you some
examples
of habits that you might not even think
about are a habit okay
and a pattern or a habit is simply
a behavior pattern we call them a loop
and I'm going to explain why
it's a behavior pattern
that is stored in the subconscious part
of the brain you'll also often hear
people talk about the basal ganglia and
the reason why you have habits is
because your brain loves shortcuts
see everything that your brain is doing
and your nervous system is doing we've
talked a lot about this in other
trainings but everything that your brain
and your nervous system is doing it
requires fuel just like your car
requires fuel for you to be able to go
from where you are right now to the
grocery store that's how it runs your
brain requires fuel
and your brain has figured out ways to
maximize
the fuel and to be more efficient
and the way that your brain is more
efficient is it learns habits and
patterns
and when you have a habit or a pattern
that you have memorized because you've
repeated it so many times it takes less
fuel for your brain to reflexively do
that pattern than doing something new
and I'll give you an example
um this is something you can test out
later today or tomorrow
I want you to think about like a place
that you often bike or drive to maybe
it's a grocery store maybe it's work
maybe it's school maybe it's friends
house
tomorrow I want you to consciously drive
an entirely new and different and longer
way and you will notice something you
will notice that your brain fights you
you'll notice that your brain is annoyed
and you will notice that it takes more
effort for you to think about where
you're headed
because the way that you commute to work
or school or the grocery store you have
repeated that so many times it is now a
pattern or a habit Loop stored in your
brain that's why often you get to places
you always drive and you're like oh my
God who drove the car because you don't
remember driving the car because your
brain was in the background making
decisions that have already been
automated so the reason why that happens
just in summary is because if you had to
use your prefrontal cortex and focus on
every aspect and every decision from how
you pick up the toothbrush to how you
hold a pencil to all that stuff you
literally would need to take a you'd
need to take a nap by one o'clock in the
afternoon you wouldn't be able to
process that much new information
and so it's a way for your brain to take
a break it learns patterns automates
behaviors so let me give you some
examples of some habits you might not
think about
picture yourself
sitting at the wheel of a car
and you put the car in Reverse which
shoulder do you look over as you're
backing up
it's always the same one isn't it and
depending upon where you live in the
world it's one side of the other
it's always the same you don't even
think about it do you
that right there is a habit
that is a reflexive action and pattern
that you do without even thinking
now think about your evening routine do
you lock the door every night
at home
do you have a pattern or habit of things
that you just go through in your house
reflect you don't even think about it
right
you're not like oh it's time to lock the
door about where is the door I can't
remember how to do I better Fortune no
you just get up you walk to click the
lock and it's just a pattern that you do
that is triggered by the end of the
night
here's the second thing I want you to
know about patterns
patterns repeat
if you don't
interrupt a pattern and replaced it with
something else the pattern will repeat
forever
so learning new behaviors and learning
new habits
is a lot more
about spotting the things that you don't
want to do anymore
and interrupting them
and then replacing those old patterns
with new patterns
and I believe that when you start to
feel broken or stuck in your life
you're not broken you have a pattern
from your past that makes you feel
broken based on where you want to go now
and I also believe that when you feel
stuck in life you're not actually stuck
you're just stuck repeating these old
patterns and until you catch them
and you interrupt them which is where
the five second rule comes in there's
nothing more powerful to help you
interrupt an old pattern than counting
backwards five four three two one to
interrupt the loop but then you have to
replace it with something else
because if you don't replace the pattern
what's rule number one about patterns
patterns repeat
so you can't just break a habit
technically you don't break a habit
technically you replace it with
something else there will never be
another you
there never been another you there will
never be another you that will ever walk
this Earth
you are the one and only which means you
have something extraordinarily unique to
give to the world
and feeling celebrated and feeling seen
and feeling heard
it is so tied into your existence
because of how unique you are that's why
you long
to be recognized as an individual that's
why you long to be celebrated as an
individual this need it's so important
and foundational to you and the fact
that your birth and existence is a
miracle
that it's as important to your
well-being to be seen and heard and
appreciated as food and water
the difference between a good day and a
bad day you know what it comes down to
typically is just being acknowledged by
somebody
and you know who's the best person to
acknowledge and validate you you are and
that brings me back to that moment every
single morning when you come face to
face with yourself in the mirror
high-fiving yourself is so much more
than a physical act it's foundational
it's a transfer of energy it symbolizes
an alliance and a belief in yourself and
your ability you aren't congratulating
yourself you're celebrating yourself as
you are
and you just heard the math Your
Existence is what makes you worthy of a
high five your presence your hopes your
dreams Your Capacity to love your
ability to heal to change to grow your
heart your soul
That's What Makes You worthy of being
seen and heard
and appreciated
not once in a while
but every single day that's what you
deserve
that's what you need
and the Miracle of your existence is why
you need it
see when you
are able to see yourself
when you are able to celebrate yourself
when you are able to treat yourself in a
way that you have been wishing your
parents would have or wishing your
friends or your spouse or your boss
would when you take control
this is what you communicate it's
incredible
you're basically when you're able to
hear yourself and see yourself and
support yourself and I believe that
simply adding a high five in the mirror
to yourself as part of your morning
routine every single day you start the
day by fulfilling
those foundational needs that the
miracle of your birth demands of you one
of the things that I have to do is I
have to stop holding on to misery I've
got to stop holding on to my own habit
of hesitating and overthinking and
feeling scared and gripping and I'm
working on it
um
so I want to know what are you getting
out of this
and I see oh I love this I see so many
of you going oh my God happiness is so
unfamiliar happiness is so unfamiliar
trauma that you haven't released I
relate to this holy cow I'm so glad that
you do
I remember a couple months ago I was
doing a bunch of research for
um a project that we're doing for
audible about happiness was one of the
episodes that we were working on
and it was kind of striking to me that
the research around happiness shows that
folks that feel happier and are present
to more joy in their life have a habit
that those of us that sort of grip
tightly and feel a little wound up and
stressed and have a hard time relaxing
don't have and that habit that happy
people have is that they make time to do
things
that make them feel happy
and when I started digging into that
research it was a little confronting
because I thought holy
I don't even allow myself I'm so gripped
to feeling stressed out and intense and
bracing for what's next that I haven't
even made it a priority to allow myself
and so becoming a happier person again
I'm going to go back to what I said
earlier in this broadcast the first step
is literally letting go stop gripping
let go of what's no longer serving you
because holding on to it hurts a hell of
a lot more than letting go of it
and so wherever in your life you are not
happy happy or you are just bracing or
stressed or if stuff isn't working I
guarantee you you're gripping onto
something a relationship a job a habit a
routine a place that you live a mindset
you're gripping onto something that no
longer serves you
and gripping to it is going to cause you
so much more pain and misery than
letting go
it's really that simple
every single ending in your life has a
brand new beginning contained into it
that's it every single ending
that you are avoiding in your life
inside that ending there is a new
beginning I am right in the thick of
this which is why I'm talking about it I
love myself because I feel comfortable
in my own skin I love myself everybody
because I don't label myself as a bad or
selfish or broken or whatever person
I just encourage myself I give myself
compassion and I work hard every day to
maintain that kind of relationship with
myself I have truly stopped victimizing
myself and I have empowered Myself by
encouraging and being compassionate with
myself
and you're meant to feel this way about
yourself too this is how you're meant to
feel you're you're meant to feel
comfortable in your own skin you're
meant to feel proud of yourself you're
meant to feel celebrated and encouraged
by yourself and look I still don't live
on the right Street I still don't belong
to that Country Club I can't go back and
redo my college and my law school years
but
here's what I can tell you you can break
the habit of beating yourself up over
the past you can break the habit of
constantly victimizing and bashing
yourself you can break the habit of
labeling yourself with these horrible
labels and indicting yourself by saying
you are this way no the behavior that
you engaged in may have sucked back then
but you don't suck you're just a human
being and you're figuring things out and
now that you know what you need to do
better you can do better the reason why
visualization and picturing yourself
succeeding and allowing yourself to feel
the happiness and the pride that comes
with picturing a positive future the
reason why that's as important is let's
say Shelley does that every single day
this week every day she wakes up she
walks for five minutes and as she's
walking on that treadmill she's
visualizing herself finishing a 10K in
six months and how proud she is every
time she does that she is changing
what's going on up here
this isn't something I made up this is
true
and it's not only true based on science
but let's think about this from a common
sense perspective if Shelley wakes up or
if you wake up every single morning and
instead of thinking about the worst case
instead of looking at your body in the
mirror and going I'm so fat I'm so out
of shape I'll never run a 10K this is
never going to happen why didn't I
exercise last year I hate my flabby
stomach I hate my my big thighs I hate
how out of share I'm embarrassed like if
that's what you're thinking
then that is what you're allowing your
brain to continue to filter the world
through
if you start teaching yourself the skill
of visualizing a positive outcome and
feeling the pride that comes with
achieving that positive goal what
happens for you right now is you start
to think like the kind of person that
does a 10K
if after an entire week what Shelley
does is she looks in the mirror and she
goes I'm getting stronger every day I'm
really proud of myself even though I'm
I'm feeling flabby I'm not saying you're
flabby Shelly but even though I'm
feeling flabby I'm doing the work I can
do this what happens a week from now is
when she sees a registration for a 10K
the old mind that wasn't programmed
correctly would go oh you're fat you're
out of shape you're not prepared for
that don't sign up
but the new mind
because she's been visualizing every
single day the new mind just seven to
ten days later is going to go oh wait a
minute I'm gonna say I'm proud I'm doing
this why do you sign up
it's gonna filter the world in a very
different way because you're training it
to this is the heart of doing a mindset
reset and this is why visualization
works and why it's an important step and
why I'm so glad you're doing it if you
know the moment that you started to
think wow I got to change myself to fit
in I can't be gay I can't have kinky
hair I don't like the color of my skin
because I feel like there's something
wrong with me Society gave you that
message your parents did
um maybe a bully said something to you I
see somebody writing the way that I walk
I see somebody talking about the texture
of their hair I see somebody saying I
always felt like there was something
wrong with me well let me tell you
something everybody I never fit in with
any particular groups of friends let me
tell you something every one of you is
now going I remember that feeling
because I was the only immigrant in my
class I would because the only Muslim in
my class I didn't look like the other
people I didn't feel like the other
people my father was so critical right
when you start to get this message from
society or other people or just this
perception that you have that
something's wrong with you this is where
your obsession with changing yourself to
fit in begins this is where your
obsession with people pleasing this is
where this sense that you don't belong
anywhere that you go began and it can
become a habit and so we're going to
unpack this because what I want you to
understand is that you literally
you literally came into this world
perfect whole and complete you are wired
to love yourself you're wired for love
that's why you miss it you're wired for
self-acceptance and the world taught you
that there's something about you that
needs to be changed in order to be liked
or loved and it's simply not true
when you can come back home to yourself
and you can accept and love yourself
first exactly where you are exactly
where you're not
then you'll know the secret to going out
in the world and not feeling like you
never really belong anywhere or you
constantly need to tweak yourself or how
you show up in order to be accepted by
people when you accept yourself as you
are when you love yourself as you are
other people liking or loving you is
just a bonus but it doesn't change how
you feel about yourself
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Tom bill you
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there you must say
that noise you cannot allow yourself to
say that I'm too old ever again I don't
care if you're 98 you know that you have
15 seconds left to live don't buy into
the myth that you're too old because
that is going to slow you down